arriving in Belgium from outside the
Schengen area and Evon of these to get
me through and this is how it used to be
across the whole of Europe before the
creation of the Schengen area what is
between working countries were closed
and often crossing the border between
Luxembourg and France seems perfectly
natural to us with all the checks on
documents car searches and
administrative procedures making things
slow for citizens it was sometimes
difficult to feel truly European with so
many obstacles to free movement Schengen
is now a landmark name and it was this
tiny village in Luxembourg that gave its
name to the Schengen Agreement when in
1985 France Germany and the Benelux
countries met together to bring about
the end of their internal borders but it
wasn't until the 26th of March 1995 just
20 years ago that the agreement came
fully into force the agreement was one
of the first steps in formalizing
enhanced cooperation between member
states and the European community
outside of EU treaties first they had to
overcome the opposition of several
member states before they could bring
about their ambitious plans for the free
movement of people's it was with the
signing of the Amsterdam treaty in 1999
for the new framework known as the Sheng
a key became fully integrated into the
EU is the Schengen Agreement
those heifers is to do away with border
controls the real horses cooperation
between the police official and customs
authorities in the country to find the
agreement it also paves the way for the
countries to work jointly on
strengthening their external borders
today 22 out of the 28 EU member states
are part of the Schengen area together
with some non EU countries such as
Norway Iceland and Switzerland
some countries have special advantages
this is true for Denmark the Danish can
choose to apply or not for any new
measures and the United Kingdom and
Ireland not formally part of the
Schengen area can still participate in
certain provisions of the Shing and a
key as can Bulgaria the Cyprus Republic
Croatia and Romania one of the tools for
strengthening the police cooperation is
the Schengen information system or sis
to for example police in one country can
help arrest wanted criminals from
another country or tracked and stolen
objects all essential for the Schengen
area to function properly
city member countries have their borders
open all of the time for some exceptions
apply for example a country to decide to
re-establish its border controls
for reasons of national security of
public order as France did in the summer
of 1995 when it was faced with a series
of terrorist attacks and since October
2013 has been possible to reinstate
border controls for a maximum duration
of 24 months in exceptional
circumstances that is when controls at
the external border of the Schengen area
can no longer be guaranteed a great
majority of enemies here in the
Europeans the Schengen Agreement and
actually are the backbone of the EU
freedom of movement is seen as one of
the fundamental freedoms